quand on pense à la france on pense
évidemment à ses fromages à la tour
eiffel ou encore à afida turner
mais il existe aussi c'est incroyable
talent m6 nous montre depuis maintenant
15 ans sublime parce que je viens
d'entendre hier c'était donc l'épisode 4
de la nouvelle saison et on a pu
découvrir des talents assez varié avec
entre autres un gars un peu musclé qui
aime bien soulever des trucs lourd
[Musique]
et aussi porter des mecs pas du tout à
l'aise qu'est ce que je fous là et on a
découvert christophe surnommé fils de
flûte qui a fait une reprise de pif 600
avec un balai à chiotte aussi on a vu
une dame qui avait un dalmatien un bar
un peu chelou et une autre piégé dans le
baquet cellophane de son sandwich
tandis qu'un mec qui savaient pas quoi
faire de toutes les pâtes qu'il a acheté
pour le confinement c'était éliminé par
le jury
bon c'est une escroquerie aux c'est un
non désolé enfin comme toujours on a le
droit de belles prestations aussi comme
celle de lou hahn
[Musique]
une jeune non voyante qui a bénéficié du
gordon brown
bravo elle même si nous on a déjà notre
petit préféré
all away
telleria jean baptiste guégan qui nous a
rejoint merci jean baptiste d'être là en
jean baptiste qui revient comme je
voulais me je vous le dire il sera
demain rythme en plus d'en apprendre à
laisser jean baptiste guingamp qui
revient avec un album resté le même ce
titre est fou et l'album est très très
fort jean baptiste est déjà disque d'or
bravo j'avais déjà paris barry déjà déjà
que ce qu'ils disent que leur sein mais
non monsieur que c'est sa maman
domotique ça va très bien vous avez
encore incroyable talent ont pas oui
enfin j'ai regardé hier j'ai regardé oui
mais mais j'en garde surtout un souvenir
extraordinaire c'est normal parce que
j'ai fait des énormes rencontre dans
cette émission que ce soit les talents
que ce soit les les jurys voilà c'est
vraiment excellent et depuis vous vivez
un rêve de cartonner vont ils changer en
battisti cartonne et comme je le dis à
rester le même le titre de son album
c'est vraiment jean baptiste qui restent
elles-mêmes voilà il fait son trou et
qui fait son taff et ça vous est pas
monté à la tête parce que c'est vrai que
quand on émerge comme ça dans une
émission ça peut vite faire tourner la
tête et on vous pose la question y at il
vraiment des talents dans incroyable
talent alors c'est donc une des
émissions phares de m6 a cartonné hier
soir mais on peut parfois se demander si
elle porte bien son nom incroyable
talent le côté incroyable ils l'ont mais
le côté talent parfois c'est pas où
regarder
il grandit
ta trou à l'autre je ne fais que ça de
patrouille et chaussées
[Musique]
les
gevrey
tous
tu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
paul et péter propos polémiques les
poteaux paul et y est voilà c'est vrai
qu'il ya de tout dans incroyable talent
on vous pose la question y at il
vraiment des talents dans incroyable
talent gilles verdez y en a pas ce sont
les caricatures de talent cette saison
c'est terrible c'est pierrot avec ses
crottes de nez aux rosiers avec son
cheval hier soir c'est un faux cet hiver
et ça a cartonné mais oui mais c'est un
festival du mauvais goût je réponds
clairement il ya aucun talent et en plus
les les jurés se moque des gens
donc c'est un festival de moqueries je
trouve ça très très violent et le pire
c'est le jury ce jeune homme il arrive
il est mignon le petit pierrot mais
cyril je sais que vous détestez ça mais
il dit mais crottes de nez je les
éparpiller dans la choucroute ou dans la
purée et là ils adorent ça des paroles
elle va s'extasier en disant mais c'est
fou on dirait des chansonniers comme
bourvil ou fernand non mais c'est pas
possible a dit sa haine ségara d'aller à
bourvil ou fernandel est terrifié il ya
un monsieur qui est venue à son exposé
était tout à fait un jeu porte des
machines à laver ou des frigos waouh
incroyable déménagement de la face et
non mais on n'a plus peur ensuite il a
porté
karine le marchand et on a plus parlé
sur mon décolleté de carême le maire
garde est de savoir humain marchand qui
nous a fait une sophie marceau hier
regarde pas les agriculteurs qui vont
soulever comme ça
[Musique]
bon est-ce que cet endroit
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
at least un enfer
quant à mes dessins magnifiques moi je
suis désolé je pense comme ça c'est un
vrai talent c'est un vrai talent je suis
désolé isabelle on est d'accord il ya
des concours de force to me sens
justifie que parce que justement il ya
dès lors le monsieur de 80 pour 80 ans
effectivement n'hésitent-ils lira jamais
jusqu'en finale mais c'est drôle est
amusant à voir et le public aime bien
c'est une détente et virgule c'est ça
c'est ça qu'on tisse et jean michel
maire non c'est pas un talent de portée
des gens à bout de bras ccsa mail de
l'entraînement ce tournoi la salle trois
heures par jour
mozart s'intallant mais porter les
choses comme ça où geneviève du truc
c'est pas un talent on dit que vous
allez dans n'importe quel cas pareil
vous en trouver mais moi quand je vais
au spectacle de fin d'année ma fille
jouer les choses aussi bien que sarah
léger cola pernikoff je trouve qu'on
s'éloigne de la province de l'émission
départ était incroyable talent il y
avait énormément de talent il y avait
des cabarets y avait des numéros de
cabaret y avait pas mal de chose qui
ressemblait aussi à ce qu'on trouvait
chez patrick sébastien là aujourd'hui je
trouve que c'est effectivement un
melting-pot de un peu forte ou de
n'importe quoi et puis cette année je
trouve particulièrement on se moque un
peu des gens là le jury
j'aimerais ça c'est ce qui me dérange il
ya eu deux trois particulièrement
mauvaises qu'on l'ait pas qu'on va dire
celle de marianne james et les besoins
des gens message tu fais ça nourrit ce
soir vous plaire été un peu dur eric r b
moment il faut se les envois des x 50
dans la journée et que en fonction du
montage on se dit [ __ ] bien des fois
ils en ont marre alors il faut aussi
être honnête c'est vrai que l'émission a
révélé devrait grand talent connaît
encore aujourd'hui qui font une carrière
de ouf comme jean baptiste jean baptiste
toit en 2018 tu va tout casser on s'est
très vite dès qu'on doit la première
fois que tu va remporter incroyable
talent tout le monde l'avait dit si att
l'immense favori d'ailleurs il avait
fait la bande-annonce autour de toi je
m'en rappelle avant même que tu passes
regardez
[Musique]
je me tue
mais laurent
suis je
[Musique]
alors oui mais ça c'est ça c'est le
meilleur exemple est fait avance
l'émission il avait dit amélie pas
autant ça l'a révélé il a un talent à
chromé là pour le coup y avait une vraie
mission montrer des gens qui sont soit
des professionnels parce que oui on peut
prendre les numéros qui viennent de
partout dans le monde
ça n'a pas d'intérêt et parfois et c'est
ce qui dérange le plus se moquer des
gens comme ça surtout ça pas bien et
c'est passé c'est pas à la hauteur de
l'émission et tout ça deviens tu as
lancé comme stars sur tf1 il ya plus de
talent l'émission naomi cas de la jeune
chanteuse de jazz dérange c'est que
chaque année on dit oui a pas assez de
français c'est un croc talent la face à
caen talent il na pas alors là cette
année
eh ben on a beaucoup de français et là
il a tous en train de critiquer le
talent des français moi je trouve des
talents je trouve qu'ils sont
formidables
bien sûr c'était pas une production du
fou il faut du moins bon et du meilleur
donc c'est sûr qu'il ya des trucs qui
sont assez drôle ça passe vite ça nous
fait rire et avoir inhalé bon jean
baptiste mais y'a pas il n'y a pas je
veux dire il n'y a pas que moi qui suis
sorti de là justement ces messieurs
justement regardons les inactifs qui a
été extraordinaire qui chantent très
très bien 2011 elle a treize ans et va
remporter cette saison avant de faire
une carrière incroyable allant de ouf
marine ariane
ça
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
révélée par importance comme le disait
jean baptiste gonnet
oui il ya desigual talent mais il ya
demain mais moi je prends le cas de jean
baptiste et moi j'ai pas tenu les les
grands talents pour le connaître parce
que enfin il ya trop quatre ânes déjà tu
y avait des vidéos de toi qui tournait
dans les supermarchés qui te souviens
c'était à la fnac oui il y avait des
vidéos cas de chute et requiem pour un
fou de dieu ni tu confirmes à la mer en
tout cas bravo
alors monsieur monsieur non moi je
trouve que là c'est totalement dévoyé et
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de talents
qui sont venus de l'étranger là comme ça
était plus difficile de les faire venir
ils ont donc pris des talents en france
il en a eu le tout venant tout importe
quoi c'est pour ça que le niveau laisse
moi c'est sur m6 donc tu m'as défendre
mais laisse moi finir le niveau est
d'une faiblesse insigne cette saison
voilà ta maman en 2017 c'est une chance
mais j'ai l'habitude jean baptiste
icônes et les messieurs je suis un fan
absolu des nations et quand j'ai vu tous
les deux des herbes côte à côte comme ça
ça me fait rire et jean baptiste notion
des fan de toi tu le sais mais jean
baptiste toi comment tu as fait pour
garder la tête froide
il n'empêche que tu as un succès c'est
un grand et un des plus gros vendeurs de
disques du moment en france qu'elle
commence tête et était resté tranquille
tu es resté le même et je je je fais mon
métier voire simplement et humblement
tue qui je kiffe ce que je fais j'adore
ce que je fais je veux dire je suis pas
chirurgien j'ai pas soigner des
personnes je suis pas je suis pas je me
suis jamais pris pour une star et je
serai jamais une star il mais je veux je
veux juste est anna voilà l'artiste si
je peux faire plaisir aux gens c'est
exactement mon rôle jean baptiste sont
aujourd'hui sur terre je te sens tu dis
moi la mairie je veux rester moi même je
te sens très heureux et épanoui vraiment
moines maladroit je suis très heureux je
te jure je trouve que tara jaunies je
trouve même ton visage
ici il est illuminé j'ai passé par des
périodes assez difficile en ce moment
parce qu'avec le coc vide et fait cuire
et tout ce qui s'ensuit
c'est vrai que c'est difficile
pour pour moi comme beaucoup d'artistes
depuis remonté sur scène depuis allez
sur les planches
je crois qu'on est tous un petit peu
dans le même cas et moi moi ma vie c'est
la scène
donc on m'interdit en ce moment de
pouvoir remonter sur scène ça n'est pas
grave je vais mourir heureux tu as l'air
sonné je suis heureux c'est le vrai
parce que déjà je suis heureux avec avec
les gens qui m'entourent et notamment ma
petite chérie de votre question qu'elle
y accéder est ce que le fait que vous
soyez si heureuse c'était grâce à une
femme mais on était heureuse grâce à une
femme donc vous avez là votre bac à ce
qu'elle dit je suis trouvé ma moitié
génial j'ai une place en finale mais il
ya michel mallory donc le symbole
historique a écrit du moins ce qu'a
écrit dix titres pour vous c'est ça
pascal obispo florent pagny et vous avez
fait un appel du pied à david hallyday
votre rêve visiblement ce serait qu'il
écrive pour vous est-ce que vous avez
une assise david il a envie de m'écrire
une chanson ou plusieurs
mon coeur est ouvert il ya aucun
problème serait génial maintenant oui ce
serait beau ce serait beau que que ça
vienne voilà mais il faut que ce soit
fait naturellement
je ne force personne à m'écrire des
chansons michel je n'ai pas forcé à
faire il a on a su se connecter comme ça
entre nous il me connaît par coeur je le
connais par coeur c'est lui qui vous a
contacté
non non non c'est ça c'est fait pas par
le biais de d'un voile adresse de
quelqu'un qui connaissait très très bien
michel et sa femme et on s'est
rencontrés je suis allé en corse à sa
rencontre
on a discuté longuement je connais le
parcours de michel mallory parker un
très gros est déjà très grand parolier
pas loin de cent quarante chansons pour
johnny hallyday avoir historique
oui oui c'est quand même voilà c'est pas
c'est pas un vilain bane et donc c'est
réussir demain je dis respect à ce
monsieur est encore plus respect parce
que parce qu'il a su me faire confiance
sur le parcours que je suis en train de
tracer en ce moment